so we have just found out officially
when the first trailer for Ant-Man and
the WASP will officially released
because it was shown behind scenes at
d23 and it has also been leaked which I
will get to at the end of this video so
you do want to stay for that but the
producer Brian Gay said this you know
I'm very excited to share that project
with you guys early next year at the
moment one thing I enjoyed about this
movie is we've always joked that the
Ant-Man movies go small but this one is
going to go big we were able to show
some things at d23 and we'll have more
coming in the fall and of course ahead
of the premiere early next year but I
will say it's fun to have the whole
family back and they're going to go on a
quite a big adventure that I think is
going to feel like a real departure from
the previous films so the full season
lands between September 23rd and
December 21. so for all my prediction
for when I think this trailer will
release officially I think it will be at
the end of October so maybe about four
weeks time but do take that River grain
of salt now the league trailer speaking
about it has actually been leaked on
online I have Linked In the description
below so you can go watch this trailer
however just in case the trailer has
been taken down by the time you've
watched this video I'm going to do a
breakdown of it now Scott hope and
Cassie are all in a car ride together
Scott is listening to an audiobook of
his own book on the car radio Cassie is
weirded out by the fact that he does
this the scene then Cuts just got
happily doing mundane things with a
voiceover of him reflecting on his past
actions we see Cassie being released out
of a jail cell presumably because she's
been getting into trouble and Scott is
there to take her home Scott is then
about to leave an ice cream store and
someone mistakenly yells thank you
Spider-Man Adam then we see Cassie Scott
Hank and Janet in a garage or lab of
some kind and Cassie reveals that she's
been studying the quantum realm into
five years that everyone was blimped
she's built some device that allows one
to make contact with the quantum realm
it's a glowing blue orb of energy that
hovers over machine Janet realizes what
Cassie is doing and tells her to shut it
off in the midst of a coral the device
emits a shock wave and sends everyone
flying back before pulling them all and
transporting them into the quantum realm
they all wake up hazy and confused and
several things are happening before Bill
Murray's character appears out of a ship
and reunites of her like their long-lost
friends we then see Kang's guards
apprehending Cassie and escort in her
and cuffs Scott is in a room with Kang
and Cassie is in the cell right behind
the Kang states that he's killed so many
Avengers that they've all Blended
together he then offers Scott a deal to
help him retrieve something that he lost
and after Scott refuses can uses some
type of magic to bind Scott to the wall
so judge and by the breakdown of the
trailer and I also did listen to the
leaked audio of it the first half of
this trailer is more like light-hearted
and they got a couple jokes in there and
then the second half of the trailer the
turn completely changes to something
more dark more urgent and like you know
this is going to have a big impact on
the MCU and Kang's lines are really
really good so one of the lines is Scott
asked cure you and he says just a man
who's lost a lot of time like you but we
can help each other with that someone
stole something for me and you're the
only one who can steal her back so do we
have a deal in which Scott responds no I
don't think we do so I'm really excited
for the more serious turn and of course
I'm most excited to see Kang but what do
you guys think let me know what you
think of this leaked trailer description
in the comment section below and what
are you most looking forward to to
seeing in this film thanks for watching
guys